bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo
week-end ce vendredi nous allons parler
de deux opérations vacances qui débutent
était en salle à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
et puis l'opération RTT remettait ton
gamin les hameaux ce sera dans quelques
instants avec nos deux invités mais
d'abord on accueille sur ce plateau
bonjour la directrice divine tourisme
avec vous on va parler de balade au fil
de l'eau
ça c'est juste une impression regardez
d'ailleurs le ciel se dégage c'est bien
tout tout est faux la météo se trompe il
va faire très très beau et donc c'est la
fête du nautisme ça fait du notice
dimanche et donc dans les Yvelines on
est on est un département qui est
particulièrement adapté puisque on a 600
km de fleuves de rivière les plus beaux
plans d'eau d'Île-de-France et donc nos
bases de loisirs les deux plus grandes
bases de loisirs des Yvelines donc
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines par exemple se
joint à la fête du nautisme en propos de
faire de la voile du catamaran de la
planche à voile également et puis
évidemment dans la base de l'ouest du
département également propose de même
type d'activités tout ça bien sûr pas
comme d'habitude c'est gratuit et puis
vous avez aussi le canoë kayak club qui
propose des activités un petit peu hors
du commun qui ne sont pas proposés
habituellement comme de la pirogue c'est
ça comme de la pire de la pirogue par
exemple on va partir loin on sait pas si
100 km de fleuve dans les Yvelines on
imagine pas
il y en a plein d'autres donc on a on a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'eau d'accord
alors on reste à la base de loisirs de
50 ans en Yvelines pour l'opération
bateau sur l'eau alors bateau sur l'eau
bien sûr comme le nom l'indique c'est
une opération qui est pas pour les
grands une opération pour les petits sur
un bassin de 84 mètres carrés exactement
oui je vous ai épargné depuis alors on
va épargner notre nos visiteurs
potentiels et donc bateau sur l'eau
c'est une opération où les petits sont
sur des bateaux gonflables donc c'est
une expérience pour eux ils sont seuls
sur leurs bateaux mais encadré bien sûr
et comme ça pour rentrer à la maison et
raconter tout ce qu'ils ont fait pendant
ce moment formidable et c'est donc tout
l'été
ça fait ça fait envie allez on reste
encore à la base de loisirs de 50 ans en
ligne pour évidemment l'ouverture de la
piscine à vague notamment et c'est les
deux choses
donc Beach au soleil c'est l'ouverture
effectivement de la piscine à vague
alors cette piscine à vague propose des
des grandes sensations avec des bas des
vagues importantes toutes les heures on
a 10 à 15 minutes de vagues pour
s'amuser et puis
au soleil c'est le beach volley le rugby
volley le Home ball faut pas que je me
trompe parce que c'est quand même plein
de noms un petit peu différents et puis
des tournois de handball dans le sable
bien sûr comme à la plage ça c'est la
base de loisirs on va pas faire un peu
plus loin de 50 ans de divine on va
aller du côté de Bougival pour découvrir
le nautique parc oui alors le nautique
Park c'est un parc nautique et c'est le
premier deal de France qui fera
peut-être des petits par la suite parce
qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup de de
communes qui peuvent s'en inspirer c'est
tout à fait nouveau c'est sur l'île de
la chaussée et on est en face des
paysages qui ont inspiré les peintres
impressionnistes donc ce sont des
bateaux des des zodiaques sur lesquels
on vous emmène donc il y a le balade la
balade en zodiaque le baptême de
zodiaque préalablement et le les
propriétaires donc de ce de type parc
ont même prévu un bateau pour handicapé
où ils peuvent faire
des promenades les enfants ont aussi un
espace qui leur est dédié l'espace
piou-piou ou ils peuvent faire du petit
du Petit Bateau du petit pédalo et son
bien encadrés donc voilà le Nautic Park
a ouvert depuis le mois de mai et
voilà et c'est jusqu'en septembre tous
les week-ends
du vélo aussi on peut avoir des tas
d'activités le long de la scène
sachant que on profite des paysages qui
ont inspiré les peintres
impressionnistes dans le dans le Vexin
donc c'est des bonnes promenades à faire
tous l'été ou enfin toute l'année même
spécialement puisqu'on est au bord de
l'eau
c'est assez joli au niveau du du visuel
qu'on peut avoir quand on se promène sur
les quatre scènes
il y a aussi l'endroit qui a accueilli
la semaine dernière les championnats
d'Europe de canoë kayak et ça c'est un
endroit extraordinaire effectivement du
kayak sur la Seine à Mantes-la-Jolie le
club qui est très prometteur et qui
beaucoup de champions allez on revient
du côté de Versailles alors là on va
aller en barque et ça va être bon en
moins remou en que sur la scène
puisqu'on va du côté du canal voilà le
grand canal du du château de Versailles
il fait du parc du château de Versailles
on peut louer des barques à la journée
pour se promener alors ça se loue à
l'heure à la demi-heure c'est une
activité assez sportive parce que ces
barques sont débarque anciennes en bois
très très lourd donc ça n'a l'air de
rien on se promène en même temps on fait
du sport il faut savoir quand même qu'on
est dans un environnement exceptionnel
le parc du domaine national de
Versailles où Louis XIV AD se promener
sur le sur le grand canal qui fait 23
hectares au total donc de temps de faire
avec voilà le temps de faire la totalité
ça prend un petit moment et puis à
l'époque de Louis XIV pour faire un
petit peu d'histoire c'était les
Vénitiens qui venaient pour pour prendre
le roi et ça court on revient sur la
scène on se baigne pas dans la Seine
dans les Yvelines malheureusement mais
par contre il y a des plages oui il y a
des plages
donc déjà revenir aux années 50 où on se
baignait
on se baignait
c'est clair donc là on peut se baigner
dans les dans la piscine avec de
Saint-Quentin mais aussi dans les
espaces dédiés qui sont dans les deux
autres bases de loisirs à Moisson et à
Verneuil et puis on a la plage d'Achères
à chair c'est donc au
nord-ouest du département et sur la
plage d'Achères il y a tout un tas
d'activités qui sont proposés toujours
la même chose le canoë kayak la voile la
planche à voile et puis on a des
baignades de surveiller qui sont
extrêmement encadrés et puis dernière
chose et non des moindres les étangs de
Hollande où là vous avez tout un tas
d'activités nautiques il y a des petits
bateaux électriques que l'on peut louer
il y a le
canoë-kayak mais il y a aussi sur le
bord de l'eau la possibilité de faire du
ping-pong de louer des rosalies de louer
des vélos
de faire des activités sportives c'est
pas loin de Rambouillet donc on est plus
au sud donc il y en a un peu partout sur
le territoire en gros on peut aller à la
place si on veut prendre l'eau ce
week-end pas par le ciel forcément si on
cherche
merci en tout cas c'est lui pour toutes
ces idées nautiques allez on va
continuer le certificat on va parler
d'une opération qui démarre ce samedi
c'est était en sable à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
alors était en sable c'est tous les ans
Régis Arel bonjour bonjour vous êtes
conseiller municipal en charge de la
jeunesse et la vie des quartiers à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ça démarre ce
samedi sur le parking du gymnase Colas
c'est jusqu'au 24 août c'est la 8e
édition alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pendant l'été en salle on fait plein de
choses on fait plein de choses en fait
il y a plein de temps forts sur ces
moments là donc on peut donc déjà
l'inauguration demain avec des forcément
une soirée Brésil parce que c'est dans
l'air du temps en ce moment donc avec
des batucada du cacao donc art martial
brésilien
tout à fait et après on a aussi donc des
danseuses brésiliennes donc ça devrait
importer un peu de soleil parce que je
pense qu'on en aura besoin demain et
puis tout au long de cette le 13 juillet
on a forcément une soirée Coupe du monde
avec un écran géant le le 9 août
finale le 25 le 25 juillet on fait une
soirée bal masquée le écoute on est une
soirée cinéma en plein air avec Tintin
et le secret de la Licorne voilà et on
finira donc le
24 août pour la soirée de clôture avec
cette fois-ci une soirée médiévale ou
une journée médiévale événements
tout ce mois et demi mais il y a aussi
pendant toute la semaine des thématiques
vous êtes assez branchés Montigny sur
tout ce qui est bien naître
donc on a plein d'ateliers dans ce sens
là mais on a aussi des ateliers pour les
enfants avec des comptes avec des on a
des BBJ des BBC pardon on a qu'est-ce
qu'on a oublié des choses encore des
ateliers d'éveil mais on a plein
d'ateliers en fait on a aussi pour les
grandes la zumba aussi dans l'air du
temps
alors ça c'est des activités qu'on peut
faire et aussi des structures qui sont
gonflables qui sont
et puis aussi on accueille on a un club
ado aussi de monstres onze 17 ans avec
des sorties qu'on a prévu en fait tout
au long de on a trois grandes sorties de
la Villers-sur-Mer ou par de la Bocasse
et puis la troisième à Cabourg voilà
d'accord ça c'est pour le club ado
tout à fait donc sinon les autres
habitants Saint-Quentin et alentours
peuvent venir profiter d'activité c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit toutes les
activités sont gratuites toutes les
ateliers les ateliers aussi toutes les
activités sont gratuites y compris des
ateliers combien d'animateurs mobilisés
alors
on a on a mobilisé toutes les ressources
en fait des maisons de quartier donc il
y a pas mal d'animateurs de mobilisés
l'année dernière pour titre d'exemple on
a eu 24000 personnes qui sont passées
sur cet événement donc c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal c'est un succès
grandissant tous les ans donc on essaie
d'améliorer tous les ans tous les ans
donc les petites questions
en plus c'est un sac qui doit être
traité pour sécurité tout problème
sanitaire donc c'est non non c'est du
sac qui vient qui est amené par un
prestataire et puis voilà qu'on achète
tous les ans voilà donc été enceinte ça
démarre ce samedi on espère un petit
brin de soleil
pour profiter des surtout des animations
brésiliennes qui auront lieu samedi aux
alentours de de 16h alors il faut dire
qu'il y a un mini train aussi je veux
pas parler du mini train minibus
peut-être non
qui va passer dans les quartiers qui qui
aura trois arrêts il y en a et ces
arrêts là ils amènent tous à alaincola
donc pour pouvoir que les gens du
quartier puisse profiter
c'est pour demain l'inauguration et
aussi pour toutes les animations un peu
spécifiques notamment le 13 où il y a la
journée Coupe du monde parce qu'il y a
aussi le feu d'artifice comme dans pas
mal de villes avec une retraite au
flambeaux aussi ça sera une journée
complète et on le prend vous savez que
donc il y a plusieurs arrêts il y en a
une place Pompidou il y en a sur
vos blédards et
de la source on a trois arrêts pour mais
on peut avoir toutes ces infos sur le
site de la ville donc voilà toutes les
informations donc à retrouver sur le
site de la ville était enceinte ça
démarre ce samedi c'est jusqu'au 24 août
je rappelle parce que c'est en plus tout
est gratuit toutes les animations sont
gratuites c'est toutes les semaines il y
a un programme différent donc du coup ça
donne des idées il y a des idées assez
diverses si on veut profiter de ça et je
rappelle notamment les les grandes dates
qui sont notamment le 13 juillet
évidemment la fête nationale et la Coupe
du monde avec un écran géant pour
assister pour assister bien sûr la
victoire des Bleus on est bien d'accord
Régis sportif c'est évidente les Bleus
vont gagner le 25 juillet le bal masqué
le 9 août cinéma en plein air Tintin Le
Secret de la Licorne à 21h et puis le 24
août soirée de clôture autour du
Moyen-Âge avec un tir euh avec des vieux
canons et tout il y aura pas de boulets
je vous assure
pas de dangereux merci beaucoup Régis
sur le plateau on va parler d'une autre
opération qui elle démarre ce lundi et
qui dure une semaine c'est remettez ton
gamin il est amour
alors du 7 au 13 juillet c'est donc
l'opération RTT moi je trouve le nom
incroyable Émilie Dubuc vous connaissez
l'origine du nom RTT pour le temps de
travail c'est plutôt amusant d'avoir
trouvé ce nom pour une opération à
l'origine donc c'est un festival donc
qui fête là sa cinquième édition
à l'origine on est parti d'une fête
d'été qui était donc organisée sur une
journée et qui s'était tendu ensuite sur
sur une semaine une dizaine de jours et
qui regroupe l'ensemble des activités
des des manifestations des différents
services qui étaient organisés à ce
moment-là donc on est parti sur RTT
on va dire ça comme ça donc du 7 au 13
juillet ça se passe dans le quartier du
buisson à la fois sur l'esplanade du
quartier et du côté de l'estaminet aussi
oui du côté de l'estaminet puisqu'on
installe aussi un village des
tout-petits qui va être réparti entre
l'estaminet et puis le l'esplanade avec
des activités dès la toute petite
enfance un jardin musical qui est
installé avec des structures
de c'est plutôt opération Zen
vous du côté de manie c'est plutôt
tourné effectivement sur tout ce qui est
musique où tourner effectivement sur la
musique et également sur tout ce qui est
activités sportives avec tout un
ensemble de structures qui vont être
installés pour l'occasion un terrain en
sable également avec un ensemble de
tournois sport collectifs qui sont
organisés par le service des sports
voilà donc tout un ensemble d'activités
qui sont mises en place des structures
c'est des trucs regonflables c'est des
on va avoir des structures gonflables
des structures acrobatiques aussi pour
les tout-petits accessibles des trois
ans
une cage à grimper aussi qui va être
installée sur le samedi donc là avec qui
fait 8 mètres de haut et avec un
toboggan
voilà qui permettrait atterrir sur
l'esplanade
ensuite on a tout un ensemble d'ateliers
donc qui démarre le lundi après-midi
avec des la confection de costumes de
masques et d'objets roulants qui vont
servir justement toute la semaine à
préparer un défilé qui va être organisé
le vendredi et un nouveau défi 30 juin
jusqu'à ce samedi on récupère
de type à construire avec la population
parce que ce qu'il faut savoir que c'est
une manifestation qui est programmée
avec les associations donc bien en amont
donc de façon totalement participative
puisque on définit ensemble le thème le
les dates les lieux etc et puis on
travaille ensuite au contenu de façon
régulière avec les associations de la
ville
voilà et puis donc pour construire tout
tout ce programme qui pour tous ouverts
à tous Mani quoi et extérieur donc
entièrement gratuit
et puis
c'est pour régaler en fait tous les
donc pareil on aura une déprogrammation
en soirée aussi avec du théâtre en plein
air qu'on organise en partenariat avec
la PRC qui est l'association pour le
rayonnement de Port Royal des champs
donc c'est une pièce de théâtre qui est
présentée dans le cadre des portes du
temps à Port-Royal et donc on accueille
aussi au quartier du buisson pour une
représentation
donc le mercredi ensuite le jeudi donc
nous c'est toute la semaine prochaine je
dis le jeudi on a du cinéma plein air
également avec tout un programme sportif
juste avant fitness tournoi de foot
voilà un ensemble de choses et puis le
vendredi donc le défilé avec les enfants
le samedi on terminera la journée avec
un concert de mini Noga et les tambours
du Sud voilà et puis le dimanche le 13
juillet avec le bal le feu d'artifice
voilà la clôture de la semaine et le
défilé
c'est sur deux jours le carnaval oui bah
disons que on a tous les ateliers de la
semaine et les ateliers du le samedi qui
correspondent à des publics qui sont pas
forcément les mêmes du coup on a choisi
de le faire en deux fois pour permettre
à chacun de participer à un événement de
fin d'atelier donc ça veut dire quand
même il faut s'inscrire si on veut
notamment
bien sûr on prendra les inscriptions sur
place du jour pour le lendemain en
fonction des places voilà sans problème
il y aura de la place pour tout le monde
vous savez combien de personnes vous
avez accueilli l'année dernière alors
c'est toujours difficile à évaluer
non après nous on
a estimé à peu près autour de 200 à 300
personnes par jour voilà après c'est
vraiment en fonction de des ateliers on
va avoir des ateliers avec des toutes
petites jauges pour les tout-petits sur
l'éveil musical on va être sur des sur
des jauges très réduites sur des
activités plus en accès libre des
structures des structures de grimpe etc
là ça va être un flux continu donc voilà
ça c'est des choses ça veut dire que
vous vous êtes plutôt orienté vers les
plus jeunes
autour des bébés et des moins de trois
ans enfin voilà qui débarrassait tout
donc elle est terminée dans les
spectacles qu'on propose et les actions
qu'on peut mener du coup c'est un peu
dans la continuité aussi de ce qu'on
fait avec un travail autour de ce public
avec les assistantes maternelles avec
les parents les centres de loisirs et
puis voilà tout le public on peut
toucher du quartier et de l'extérieur
parce qu'à à Montigny c'est les enfants
mais c'est surtout plus la famille non
on peut se familier pour les enfants
parce qu'on a des comptes on a des tous
les jours c'est vrai que la famille tous
les tous les dimanches on a le barbecue
ouvert à tout le monde donc c'est vrai
que c'est très familial donc on fait
mais c'est pour tout le monde participer
les associations la même manière ah oui
important on ne cesse de le dire ok ben
merci en tout cas minidaire de cette
opération donc c'est du 13 c'est du de
lundi 7 pardon jusqu'au vendredi 13
juillet
dimanche 13 dimanche 13 au 13 juillet là
on est d'accord sur les dates du 7 au 13
juillet ça dure une semaine c'est
opération un remède et ton gamin et les
hameaux et toutes les informations
retrouvent évidemment sur le site
internet et c'est ouvert à tout le monde
Mani quoi ou pas Mani quoi et surtout
c'est gratuit donc
idem pour Montigny je rappelle aussi qui
était en sable c'est gratuit donc c'est
l'occasion de profiter d'activités pour
l'été de façon gratuite merci en tout
cas à vous d'être venu sur le plateau du
7 8 weekend on finit cette émission on
va parler on passe tout de suite
l'agenda du weekend
allez plusieurs à retenir en cette fin
de semaine nous partons tout d'abord à
Versailles pour une exposition qui ne se
tient que ce week-end consacré aux
travaux d'artistes souffrant de troubles
psychiques alors de c'est un peu de
l'art brut par excellence à découvrir au
domaine de Madame Elisabeth jusqu'à
dimanche une balade à vélo sur les
traces du Roi Soleil proposé par le
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cela vous en
couple simplement 3 euros avec cette
balade le musée de la ville vous
entraîne à la découverte de l'ancien
réseau d'État d'aqueduc et de rigoles de
Louis XIV ça commence à 11h ça dure 5
heures donc faites un peu sportif avec
pause et pique-nique garantie samedi
soir du cinéma en plein air ça se passe
du côté du parc du château de Buc avec
la projection de hôtel Transylvanie un
film pour les grands mais surtout pour
les enfants à partir de 6 ans mais
attention tout de la valeur c'est à 22h
en couvrez-vous parce que c'est en plein
air au Parc du Château de Buc dimanche
on va aller du côté des Clayes-sous-Bois
pour un vide-grenier solidaire donc ce
dimanche organisé par une association de
lutte contre les maladies génétiques et
les bénéfices de ce vide-grenier seront
reversés à l'Association Française
contre les Myopathies et puis dimanche
également cette fois c'est à La Verrière
c'est un festival folklorique portugais
qui se déroule au parc sportif Cousteau
ça commencera évidemment par un barbecue
de spécialités portugaise suivie de
plusieurs spectacles de groupes
folkloriques dans l'après-midi et puis
je rappelle on va parler avec Sylvie
l'avenir mais je le rappelle ce samedi
c'est l'ouverture de la piscine à vague
à la base loisirs de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour ceux qui veulent se baigner avec
des températures un peu fraîches mais le
beau temps devrait revenir la semaine
prochaine Météo France double promesse
voilà merci à mes invités d'être venu
sur place ou une 7 8 week-end et quant à
moi je vous souhaite un excellent
weekend et à très vite